hey I'm better than Cumberbatch I'm
going undercover on the Internet
it's actually me first up Twitter do you
think the doctor strange flu movements
spells were choreographed or was it just
barely come about improvising now some
thought went into them I think I think
we're kind of done with the kind of
circular movement will see that evolving
I think although the hand movements in
general the bigger spells that was
really carefully choreographed and it
was Julian who's this amazing Tata which
is the word before kind of like
breakdancing he's an expert in creating
incredible shapes and singing possible
conjunctions an opposite thing is at
hand wrist and then receiver he'd give
me something that was impossible and I'd
say look I'm an actor and we break it
down into comebacks so that I could
actually do it and it looks reasonably
good and like I had some possession of
what I was supposed to be doing next
question what's your favorite part about
being on set with the Avengers my
favorite part about being on set with
the Avengers is the camaraderie and the
companionship is just a fun place to be
odd like long hours but you spend a lot
of time in isolation getting ready and
prep being bring the costume on and the
makeup can take a long time and then
you're down you're on the field and
you're doing what you're doing with an
amazing like this thank you so it's kind
of inspiring for the carotids and once
you've got over being starstruck it's
just a really fun day in the office as
you can imagine no but fun Ryan Fuller
was - no ha ha have you ever seen
Benedict Cumberbatch tried to say
penguin Daisy you just did burning
Baumann Marie that's her name says
better than commotion the current war as
opposed to the current war it looks
interesting but why are so many u.s.
citizens being portrayed by Brits maybe
that's just perception Benedict
Cumberbatch plays come so soon
I don't know I didn't get to share quite
a lot of traffic in that department my
friend
Bernadine you know Wall Street gets to
play market action I don't know listen
it's it's a antigen job and you get to
be a lot of things other than yourself
and
not when I drop it then you just have to
be good at it and if you are getting you
get trusted to do something like playing
an American icon like Edison
we work very hard to honor the trust and
hope that people have in you so I don't
know if it is just Brits meeting
Australians as well there are lots of
other than American actors playing
American roles but I do think if the
traffic goes both ways and that's a very
healthy state of affairs culturally you
shouldn't all be typecast or stick tight
I know sweetie do you think Robert
Downey jr. and Benedict Cumberbatch ever
share Sherlock Holmes story they'll
fight over us are we tending to fight
over who the best shot occurs and I'm
really lucky you're working if two
franchises playing iconic characters and
you know Johnny Lee Miller's also a
friend and it's interesting I had to
have a real discussion about that
what's your name really I mean yeah
we've set up funny and as we get to play
these characters and here we are doing
something together and a completely
different world different characters
it's a bit of dancer isn't it shoulda
said yeah we do and I'm the best
probably IMDB font and misinformation
okay so my five trademarks are parenting
that I've got a deep baritone voice
piercing blue-green eyes and sharp
cheekbones often portrays posh
upper-class figures and I'm tearing
wasn't necessarily upper-class to
strangers very privileged and very smart
but necessary upper-class is more the
class and money and I guess in this
country yeah American posh people are
just people who aren't upper-class I'd
like to mix it up it also uses highly
intelligent and pivoted appearances but
yeah I got an odd face maybe that's why
I get to pretend to be smart but I'm
player character coming up in trouble
win in a film called
ironbark who's working-class salesman
who worked as well at the greasy fast
polka being a middle-class salesman
married into somewhat from the upper
classes but still he was basically a
salesman for industrial goods and ended
up being a conduit for mi6 turning cold
war and making plans of the highest
ranking started officially determined
Oleg Penkovsky in Russia and he was a
very ordinary man doing an extraordinary
thing so take that IMDB he experienced a
terrifying carjack in South Africa well
finger to nose at the other 2005 he
wrote about the experience in and asked
for the prince who was trust which he is
an ambassador a true tritter drew about
how music can inspire you in a
particular piece that radiated came on
by accident whilst we were being driven
rode by three guys coming to rake the
car pooler's worth toss up and
psychologically kind of torture us and
give us a pretty rough ride thank God
not too much violence I was put in the
boot of car my hands tied behind my back
and gun put to my head so that was a
sparky night in a very big country
famous for my unwritten impressions yes
God rest his soul
sometimes doesn't that - you're looking
for the infinite I really say this it's
gonna be awful I hate on TV if you can
know that if you can remember that in
the chaos it will thank you and give
with grace and ease I don't know I must
have been tired stoned or jet like that
all of those things I think you can
remember that in the chaos what chaos
chaos of Fame I mean you don't look for
the infinite and fame I don't know I
really don't know where the context of
this was or even if I said it and trust
me the amount of [ __ ] I'm credited with
saying that I haven't said is
unbelievable reddit what what are the
best names you've had for Benedict
Cumberbatch anymore so we don't have
anymore
goodbye reddit if Keanu Reeves buddy
that how much were in a movie what would
the pop I don't know we were friends and
kicked ass I don't know Wikipedia he
subscribes to Buddhist philosophy and
has expressed affinity for meditation -
yes absolutely
yeah Cumberbatch did not achieve
international recognition until the
first series of shock in 2010 since been
called the thinking woman's crumpet yeah
I was very weird that that sudden moment
and it was it's all it's the first time
I've really experienced the live nature
of a recorded broadcast it was just
bizarre like internet reaction I didn't
really know what Twitter was until that
night I didn't know that there was this
sort of space for a live reaction from
the audience kind of thinking this just
blew up in that moment to the point that
I thought we were gonna walk out the
door and have like press abseiling out
of helicopter
laughter bells going off in headphones
because it was so loud and yet I just
walked down those it's a slightly wet
empty straight normal life continued
it's great that series got so much love
and our work was rewarded and we got to
do so much other things as artists that
freedom is great with the cost of that
is Fame and that's a weird unruly beast
in September 2016 appear on stage at
Pink Floyd remember David Gilmour join
one of the musicians shows in London
held at the roller ball he sang lead
vocals and comfortably numb' singing the
first section originally sung by Roger
Waters and I'm proud because I literally
I survived to tell you that that is true
I thought I was gonna have a heart
attack I was looking for guys in like
flurries to de literally know where my
art was medically because it was like
that this is it that's it that sort of
non feeling this shortness of breath my
chest is tightening I'm going to
collapse I'd watched this entire concert
and it was a gift to any fan of Gilmour
and then I what a lot of people go what
sharks gotta sing to us you know it was
very very weird but then I got into it
it was amazing but I literally thought I
was gonna die before I went on so sorry
I just I wanted to take that one is it
like it isn't like a public forum where
people answer them what got you I think
I dunno this is better than Chemosh the
best Sherlock Holmes of all time that's
that's nice
which better than come about to
character role do you like the best
I don't your favorite sorry you'll have
to decide these things or cure you're a
teacher
why doesn't Benedict Cumberbatch have
any social media accounts it's terrible
it takes too much time like we do it how
many times they're better they can much
read Sherlock Holmes almost again in
secara pretty much every time he did a
series anything that it touched on I'd
go back to the Canon and just kind of
brutal around in it and that's the best
research you could possibly do for my
comic role like that it's all that all
that Watson recorded it all
thank internet for questions goodbye
it's not really as a hologram
I'll give up the chef